ماذا يعني ذلك إذا
أوقفت الولايات المتحدة التمويل
أه مساعدة أوكرانيا مساعدة أوكرانيا
نعم جيمي في كلمة واحدة ستكون
كارثة والسبب في كونها
كارثة هو أن أوكرانيا
تعتمد حقًا على نوع المساعدات التي نقدمها  نحن
نقدم ذلك من حيث
الأرقام الهائلة بالدولار أه أكبر مانح
للأوكرانيين من حيث نصيب الفرد من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
هناك دول أخرى مثل
بعض دول البلطيق التي
تتبرع في الواقع بأكثر مما نحن أه
ولكن من حيث الأرقام الأولية  نحن
أكبر جهة مانحة منفردة للأوكرانيين
ولدينا أيضًا الأسلحة، لذا من وجهة
نظر عسكرية، ما تنظر
إليه جيم هو الوضع الذي
تصل فيه كل الذخيرة إلى أوكرانيا أو على
الأقل جزء كبير منها أه
توقفت في خط الأنابيب في مرحلة ما،
فلن يحصلوا على دبابة أبرام
أكثر مما لديهم بالفعل،
ولن يحصلوا على طائرات F-16 التي
طلبوها، ولن
يحصلوا على أي من قذائف الهاون العالية  الأنظمة
التي حصلوا عليها والتي سيحتاجون
إلى استبدالها، أنت تعرف بعض
الأجزاء التي قد تتآكل، لذا
سيتوقف كل ذلك وفي جوهره ما
ستراه هو الهجوم المضاد
إذا اعتقدنا  لقد توقف الأمر الآن
وسيتوقف بالفعل وسيكون الخطر هو
أن الروس قد
يأتون بعد ذلك ويشنون
هجومًا مضادًا وسيكون
لدى الأوكرانيين أجهزة أقل بكثير لإيقافهم،
وهذا
وضع خطير للغاية وسيحدث حقًا
عكس كل المكاسب التي
حققها الأوكرانيون حتى الآن،
وأعني حاليًا أبعد من ذلك فقط
آليات دعم
الأوكرانيين وتسليحهم أثناء
قيامهم بهذا الهجوم المضاد، أعتقد
أي نوع من البيان سيرسل إلى
العالم  إذا قامت الولايات المتحدة
فجأة بسحب البساط من تحت أقدام
الأوكرانيين، وما هي الرسالة التي
سيتلقاها فلاديمير بوتين في الكرملين
لأنه يبدو مما
تقوله هو أنه
ربما يرى فلاديمير بوتين بعض الشيء  الضوء الأخضر
هنا يمثل فرصة لتكثيف الأمور
ومعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانه سحق الأوكرانيين
بينما ربما تكون لديه فرصة
إذا بدأت الولايات المتحدة في
التذبذب، نعم هذا هو
بالضبط ما هو عليه وأه
أنت تعرف جيم عندما ينظر الكرملين إلى
إنهم يبحثون عن أي علامة
ضعف ونوع نقاط الضعف التي
يبحثون عنها ستكون شيئًا
مثل التوقف والتمويل أو التوقف
في خط الإمداد سواء كان ذلك بسبب
التمويل أو بعض المشكلات التشغيلية التي يركزون عليها
حقًا  فيما يتعلق بهذه الأنواع من
الأشياء، وفيما يتعلق بالإشارة إلى
بقية العالم بما
ستتعامل معه، هناك أيضًا
إشارة ضعف وقلة العزيمة من
جانب الولايات المتحدة أه أنت
تعلم أنك تبدو نوعًا ما  في هذا المنظور،
ربما من السبعينيات والثمانينيات، قارن بين
ما كان يُنظر إليه في الولايات المتحدة وكيف
كان يُنظر إلى الولايات المتحدة في السبعينيات من القرن الماضي في
أوروبا وفي الاتحاد السوفييتي، ومن ثم
كيف كان يُنظر إلى الولايات المتحدة في
الثمانينيات، لقد كان عالمًا من الاختلاف
و  إنه أه في جوهره أن السلام
من خلال عقيدة القوة هو الذي يصبح
مهمًا وفي هذه النتيجة الطبيعية
لذلك سيكون عليك توفير الإمدادات للأشخاص
الذين يقاتلون نيابةً عنك
وفي هذه الحالة بالذات، فإن
الأوكرانيين بالتأكيد
يقاتلون من أجلنا لأنه
ينظر الروس إلى هذا باعتباره مجرد فصل واحد في
الحرب التي يقولون بالفعل إنهم
يخوضونها مع الغرب وخاصة
مع الولايات المتحدة.